Das, das, das, das Podcast UFO. UFO. Podcast UFO. UFO. Das Podcast UFO. UFO. Podcast UFO. UFO. Hallo. Pod, pod, pod, pod, podcast UFO. Hallo zum Podcast hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, haulden, ja, ich sag mal so, verschwinden, in einem unglücklichen Bootsunfall sein Leben aushauchen, als er eine junge Dame vor einem Haiangriff gerettet hat. Und ja, vor dem Gericht wurde das so ausdekliniert und... Moment, ich habe ihn gerade gegoogelt. Das sieht genauso aus wie du, nur mit einem Sombrero und einem Schnurrbart. Wie gesagt, man sagt, jeder Mensch hat einen Zwilling auf der Welt, jeder Mensch hat einen ... Doppelgänger-Alert. Doppelgänger. Ja, nee, das sind juristische Kuriositäten, die man auch einfach wegschweigen muss. Okay. Was passiert hier gerade? Sind das die Bomben-Einschläge? Weit im Dachboden, da wohnen Leute über uns. Versuchen die, uns darauf hinzuweisen, dass wir leise sein sollen? Ich glaube nicht, nein. Ich glaube, das ist ein wütendes Rumgetrampel, weil das Projekt nicht so läuft, wie es gerne laufen sollte. Ich bin ganz euphorisch. Ja? Wegen der Sonne. Oh! Es ist Sommer. Es ist Sommer. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dir aufgefallen ist. Es ist Sommer. Ich glaube, zum ersten Mal nur mit Polierung, keine Jacke mehr, dicke Jacke abgelegt und ich fühle mich wie neu geboren. Ich bin beweglich, man kann sich endlich wieder, kann ich meine Arme bewegen, mache auch dann so große, ruderte Bewegungen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich bin nicht wie Maggie Simpson, die man in diesen Sternenanzug gepackt hat, wie halt alle Kinder. So fühle ich mich auch mal, wenn man so einen Schal umhat und Handschuhe und so einen dicken Anorak, dann steht man immer so die Arme von sich gespreizt, ohne Hals, steht man in der Strasse und hofft, dass man nicht überfahren wird. Man ist nicht beweglich, man versucht so wie so ein Pinguin von vorne nach vorne zu kommen. Das abgelegt, jetzt habe ich quasi das abgeworfen und tänze wieder durch die Strasse, wie in so einem Musikvideo. Wobei ich meine Jacke auch vermisse. Ich mag es total gern, so dieses in das Jackett was reinstecken Move. Dieser Move mit der linken Hand die Jacke zu öffnen oder mit der rechten Hand. ich habe so eine Innentasche bei meiner Jacke, wo ich das hinreiten kann. Ja, was da drin, Kondome, Waffe, das Problem ist, Kondome, einfach immer so eine Packung Kondome parat. Nee, das kennt das in einem Film, so einer Linie, weißt du, die hängen so aneinander, wie so eine Wurst, wie so eine lange Wurst, wie Mini-Winis, Mini-Winis-Würstchenketten. Ja, ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch nie Kondome in einem Film gesehen, also wirklich mal so eine na, stimmt nicht, mir fallen drei Filme ein. Die Top drei Filme mit Kondomen. Nein, aber es ist tatsächlich, mir geht das ab, obwohl ich auch tatsächlich sagen muss, dass ich diese Innentasche oft falsch eingesetzt habe, weil ich wollte halt immer so lässig sein, wie es geht und so lässig gehört, dass man nicht hinguckt, während man es macht und man irgendwie so verschmitzt zur Seite guckt, währenddessen sein Handy in die Innentasche steht. Und dann aber die Tasche nicht findet. Die Tasche nicht findet und das Handy so leicht daneben steckt, wodurch es einmal durch die gesamte Jacke fällt, unten von der Jacke rausfällt, springt, am Boden liegt und man sich peinlich bücken muss. Also das werde ich vermissen. Vielleicht gönne ich mir so eine Tasche. So ein Beutel. So ein Bauchtasche-Fäschchen. So eine Bauchtasche auf der Seite. Oder irgendwie so über, so quer über die Brust, wie so eine Scherpe. Wir hatten ja Kängurus letzte Woche besprochen, ausgiebig. Und deswegen könnte man ja vielleicht auch einfach, kann man mal, hat da jemand mal eine Känguru so eine Bauchtasche umgehangen? Einfach nur so aus Redundancy-Gründen gucken, was passiert. So ein Känguru muss bezahlen und holt aus seinem Beutel so eine Tasche raus. Und holt da den Geldbeutel raus und alle so. Sorry, Kengi, was ist denn da los? Du kannst einfach in deine Tasche stecken. Oder ist da so Blut drin und so, das ist einfach nur so ein aufgeklappter. Ey, da was ich da für, weil du kannst es ja, kann man die umkrempeln. Kann man die mal einmal in der Woche, kann ein Känguru so die Tasche umkrempeln und dann mal auskehren? Ja, und dann, oh, Entschuldigung. Ne, aber was sich in meinem kleinen Mini-Bauchnabelchen schon alles ansammelt, so eine Woche lang. Oh, ich hasse meinen Bauchnabel. Ey, holy shit, aber was ist denn in so einem Beutel, Fussel,
so ein alter Fisherman's Friends
Packung? Ich glaube, du bist
irgendwann an dem Punkt, wo du da gar nicht mehr reinguckst, wo du einfach
sagst, ich überlasse das jetzt dem selbst
und seit drei Wochen habe ich da nicht mehr reingeguckt
und irgendwann kriegst du Besuch, Damenbesuch oder so
und dann musst du da mal gucken, wie du da zurechtkommst
und das dann mal so aussaugen mit so einem
Staubsauger oder so. Mit so einem
kleinen Ameisenbär, mit so einem kleinen Ameisenbär. Aber wir sind schon wieder Antenne-Kängurubeutel geworden. Ja, da kamen viele Mails rein, ihr redet seit vier Folgen nur über Kängurubeutel. Ja, gut. Flutter Karibik war nicht okay, Kängurubeutel ist nicht okay. Worüber sollen wir reden? Was soll man denn besprechen? Worüber sollen wir reden? Es passiert doch auch gerade nichts, stimmt nicht ganz. Ich bin heute wieder mit meinem Chef geflogen. Ach was, wirklich? Ja, zufällig hat er mich von Berlin dann mit nach Hause genommen. Und ich bin gerade eben gelandet, also kurz vor Jet Setter-Folge quasi. Wow. Ich bin gerade gelandet und es war fantastisch, Wetter ist draußen, ganz, ganz toll. Wir sind einmal über Lockdown Deutschland geflogen, einmal quer drüber, ist ja mit so die längste Strecke, die man fliegen kann, zumindest was jetzt die Ost-West-Strecken angeht, und echt toll. Deutschland ist wirklich einfach schön. Sehr viele Felder, man glaubt gar nicht, wie viele Felder es gibt. Viele Lidl auch? Ohne Schein, sehr viele Lidl, sehr viele Aldis. Ich dachte, das ist ein Aldi, nein, war Lidl, aber das sind so die Aufregungen, die man kurz hat in der Woche. Das sind die kleinen Freuden des Piloten. Das sind die kleinen Aufreger, die kleinen Spannungsmomente. Da hat man kurz, und ab und zu Rieckmann gesagt, so Achtung, auf zwölf Uhr ist ein Flugobjekt, ein unbekanntes Flugobjekt. Man guckt hin und dann muss man das finden. Und dann war es diesig, haben wir kurz nicht gefunden und dann war es schon sehr nah. Das war aber auch nicht so gefährlich. Also ehrlich gesagt, man wünscht sich ja fast so ein bisschen Gefahr. So ein bisschen Diesigkeit, ein bisschen Dies. Man wünscht sich Diesigkeit und man wünscht sich auch so ein bisschen Turbulenzen. Ist Dies der grösste Feind des Piloten eigentlich? Dies. Oder, ja? Dies plus. Man wünscht sich, ja, ich bin der Meinung, also wenn man dann so lange fliegt, dann braucht man auch so ein bisschen Turbulenzen. G mir so ein bisschen Wind. Ja, das stimmt schon. Es ist, glaube ich, auch so, alles, was man sich aufregend vorstellt, wird nach zwei Minuten langweilig. Du denkst ja auch so Astronaut, krass, Take-off. Dann wackelt es drei Minuten lang. Dann wackelt es drei Minuten und dann so, so, Scrabble, wer hat Bock? Geht nicht, kein Internet. Ach so. Habe ich auch vergessen. Ich sehe etwas, was du nicht siehst. Und das ist weiss. Mond? Ja. Ist eher so grau, aber ja. Da blinkt was, bei dir blinkt da was. Oh, okay. Ach so, war nur Kaffee fertig. Habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt, wie ich damals meine Frau kennenlernen habe? Und dann fängt es so an, dass einer so anfängt, seinen Stand-up auszuprobieren und man denkt, oh Gott. Ich glaube, jeder hat eine Zweitkarriere. Jeder will gucken, so, ich bin Astronaut, das hat funktioniert, aber mal gucken, ob es mit Stand-up auch funktionieren könnte, ob ich das mal so ein bisschen anreißen kann.
Aber apropos Space Exploration, der Mars Rover, Perseverance ist gelandet. Hast du es live verfolgt? Ich habe es nicht live verfolgt, nein, ich habe nur davon gehört. Ich habe live verfolgt. Ich habe es nicht live verfolgt. Und es war sehr antiklimatisch, ehrlich gesagt.
Man konnte quasi einer Animation zugucken,
wie sie etwas, wie sie suggeriert, dass etwas live passiert,
was sie nicht wissen könnten, als sie die erstellt haben. Das heißt, es war quasi einfach ein Video geguckt und dann ab und zu in diesen Raum geschneidet, wo sie sich gefreut haben, alle sehr doll. Also es war schon spannend. Aber auch nur die Animationen von so Ingenieuren, die sich freuen und die Mundwinke gehen nach oben. Ja, genau. Unreal Engine. Warum ist alles Animation. Ich denke auch so, der beste Grund für mich, dass wir tatsächlich auf dem Mond gelandet sind, und das schreie ich auch jedem ins Gesicht, der das nicht glaubt, ist, hätten wir das in einem Studio gedreht, sähe das viel besser aus. Dann hätte das einen coolen Soundtrack, dann würde der irgendwie so Luftgitarre spielen. Dann würde Hans Zimmer da noch irgendwie das Geist drüberlegen. Dann hätte man da wirklich cool, dann würde sich die Erde in seinem Visier spiegeln und so. Nein, wir haben irgendwie 13 Sekunden schwarz-weiss footage, das irgendwie gröselig ist. Das muss real sein, einfach weil es so scheiße aussieht. Das kann gut sein, ja. Und auch hier, warum brauchst du eine Animation, wenn du es einfach im Studio faken könntest? Also du kannst ja jedem Mondlandungsleugner sagen, warum müssen wir es denn dann animieren, wenn wir einfach irgendwie so einen Roboter, so einen Lego-Roboter auf einer großen Orange zeigen könnten, wie der da landet. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass das das Argument ist, was die dazu bringen, wenn du sagen, ja stimmt. Vielleicht ja doch. Hat es mal jemand probiert? Ich glaube, die werden dann sagen, ja, das wussten die ja, deswegen haben die es ja gemacht, damit wir noch mehr glauben, es wäre alles echt.
Du bist ja Teil der Lüge.
Wir haben es absichtlich schlecht gemacht.
Wir haben es absichtlich ein bisschen runtergescannt.
Nein, das geht über die.
Stanley Kubrick hat einen schlechten Film gedreht.
Nein, Stanley Kubrick sagt, stell doch mal so ein paar Extras nach hinten hin, oder lass mal da so einen Kugelschreiber schweben.
Mr. Kubrick, das funktioniert so nicht.
Doch, doch, das wird geil.
Doch, das wird geil.
Da ist er doch, guck mal.
Da ist er, er hängt hier lustigerweise vor uns ein Bild von Stanley Kubrick.
Hier ist ein Bild von Stanley Kubrick.
Und Mr. Kubrick, das funktioniert so nicht. Doch, das wird geil. Doch, machen Sie das, machen Sie das. Das wird geil. Da ist er doch. Guck mal. Da ist er. Er hängt hier lustigerweise vor uns ein Bild von Stanley Kubrick. Hier ist ein Bild von Stanley Kubrick. Und dir. Mit einem Schnurrbart und einem Sombrero. Hä? Ach so, nee, nee, das ist, ach so, wegen dem, das wollte ich nicht weg tun. Hä? Das war doch irgendwie vor 50 Jahren oder so. Ruhe in Frieden. Das tut mir. Wie alt bist du, Florentin? Das tut mir leid. Ich weiß es mittlerweile selber nicht mehr. Ist ja auch so, glaube ich, im Mittelalter. Du musstest ja selber mitzählen, wie alt du bist. Da habe ich mich auch bei einer App angemeldet und da habe ich dann mein Geburtstag um eingegeben und dann hat sie gesagt, ah, okay, also sind sie so und so viele Jahre alt. Zauberei! Magie! Hat es einfach runtergerechnet, basically. Aber ich hätte dann so überlegt, bin ich so hervieler alt?
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Ach so, vor allem so ein Mittelalter-Tinder muss ja voll sein von Leuten, die entweder sagen Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen bei Alter oder halt einfach sagen neun.
Ja, du bist nicht neun.
Ich habe neun Geburtstage gezählt. Ich kann bis neun zählen, ich bin neun.
Ja.
Schwarzer Ritter bei Alter auch einfach. Schwarzer Ritter, hä? Nein, das müssen Sie bei Beruf angehen. Ach so, ich bin mit dieser neuen Technik. So, so, so, so, sorry, so, sorry. Diese neue Technik ist mir too much manchmal. Beruf, Schwarzer Ritter. Der Schwarzer Ritter oder nur Schwarzer? Nee, Schwarzer Ritter.
Ach so, ah, okay.
Ich dachte, Sie sind der Schwarzer Ritter.
Nee, ich bin der, der vor zwei Jahren schon mal hier war, aber es kommt ja jedes Jahr.
Ich kenne nur Leute aus meinem Dorf, deswegen weiß ich nicht.
Ich dachte, es gibt nur ein, ach, das gibt es in jedem Dorf, gibt es einen Schwarzen Ritter. Es gibt mehrere Schwarzer Ritter, in jedem Film, in jedem Dorf, es gibt überall einen Schwarzen Ritter.
Ich dachte, unser Schwarzer Ritter sei der einzige.
Das ist denn so eine Art Agentur oder wie funktioniert das? Nö, es ist mehr so eine Lifestyle-Entscheidung. Einfach an irgendeinem Punkt entscheidet man sich, ja, ich bin jetzt böse. Und dann malt man sich die schwarz an, so mit Pech. Schwedt, ja? Ja. Also man sorgt dafür, dass die ganz schwarz wird, die einen möglichst lieber glänzen, die anderen lieber matt. Die Rüstung meinen sie dann. Die Rüstung genau. Und wichtig ist auch ein schwarzes Pferd. Die müssen auch schwarz sein. Schwierig zu kriegen heutzutage. Schwierig zu bekommen, müssen groß sein, schön mächtig, aussehen, Schlagwirken. Ja, und wenn Sie jetzt nicht aufhören, mir Fragen zu stellen, dann muss ich leider abstechen. Gut, dann würde ich sagen, an der Stelle, dann weiß ich genug und dann wünsche ich Ihnen weiterhin einen schönen Tag. Das wünsche ich Ihnen auch. Freundlicher Kerl. Ja, wunderbar. Was ein freundlicher. Warum denn nicht? Man denkt immer, die Leute im Mittelalter waren schlecht drauf, die waren gut drauf. Die hatten Bock. Oh, die schmassen wieder auf. Die hatten Bock. Geil, nee, die hatten Bock drauf. Warum denn auch nicht? Und, aber bei der Marslandung dachte ich mir, landest halt irgendwie, das kommt ja erst mal aus der Sicht von Aliens. Wir haben uns weiterentwickelt, muss man sagen. Die letzten Marsrover waren so wie so in dieser Luftpolsterfolie eingehüllt, umwickelt, mit Krepppapier dran, sind die quasi mehr oder weniger auf den Mars geworfen worden und sind dann da so völlig ungebremst aufgeprallt und sind dann so über Jahre ausgerollt langsam. Erst noch zwölf Jahre, bis der ausdotzt. Genau, ausgedotzt. Ausdotzprozess abgeschlossen. So wurde das dann auch genannt. Und ich glaube, da vor der ganze Zeit wieder so eine Horde Aliens auf dem Mars steht und so, oh Gott. Einfach das Facepalm-Geräusch, von deren acht Armen, die gegen den acht Stirn klatschen. Das ist mittlerweile besser geworden. Jetzt kommt so ein Advanced-Shit, erstmal Fallschirm, aber auch so ein rot-weisser Fallschirm. Also mir hat noch so eine Bitburger-Werbung oder sowas gefehlt. Wo man sagt, wer legt die Farbe fest, wer entscheidet das Farbschema? Wir als Menschheit haben jetzt so einen rot-weissen, wie so Markisen aussehen. Von so, müssen wir unser Fallschirm aussehen, da kann ich wie so ein cooles Blau haben. Ja. Oder so Marsrot oder Welcome on Mars oder so. Nein. Wizard Earth, it's great. We have lots of Lidels. We love Lidels. Why not? Lidl, Lidl. Und dann landet der und dann kamen so Raketen und haben den so hochgepustet und dann wurde der abgeseilt von so Nylon-Kram und dann langsam abgesetzt. Ziemlich fancy, nämlich cool. Da stelle ich mir vor, dass da eines in dem steht und sagen, weirdly irgendwie sophisticated, aber bestimmt ganz gut. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt zwei Rover auf dem Mars. Ich glaube, es sind mehrere auf dem Mars. Arbeiten die zusammen oder macht da jeder sein eigenes Ding? Oder es ist so ein Robo-Wars-Ding, wo der eine holt, der die Flex raus. Haben die überhaupt dem Ersten gesagt, dass ein Zweiter gelandet ist? Oder haben die gesagt, schick die mal auf die andere Seite vom Mars, während der landet? Weil sonst ist der mega angepisst. Ja, auch gut. Hä, ich glaube, die schaffst du nicht allein, oder was? Mega. Doch, aber für wen bist du?
Ihr so charakterlich.
Ich bin Curiosity.
Bist du für Curiosity und Perseverance?
Ich stelle mir beide unglaublich nervig vor.
Ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich ... Stell dir mal vor, du redest mit Curiosity. Ja. Wie bist du da hergekommen? Oh, oh, oh, sag mal, wie bist du gelandet? Wo bist du gelandet? Was ist das? Hast du andere... Was ist das da?
Oh, eine Drohne, du hast eine Drohne dabei? Ich war weg, ich bin wieder, hi.
Das ist Curiosity und Perseverance ist halt einfach so ein ehrgeiziges Arschloch. Ja, der sagt, ich will, ich, komm, wir haben jetzt noch zwei Tage Zeit, den Mars zu erkunden, du fängst erst nach links, ich fahr nach rechts. Ja. Aber ich meine, das wäre natürlich auch eine Podcast-Idee, die beiden, als nächstes kommt so ein Mikrofon, das nächste, was sie auf den Mars schießen, ist so ein Mikrofon.
Ja, von uns.
Genau, DPU gesponsert.
Wie viel mit so einem
Podcast-Ufo-Parachute. Ja,
wir brauchen nur ein großes Katapult, so eine große
Armbrust und schießen das auf. Sehr viel Luftpolsterfolie.
Wie viel Luftpolsterfolie braucht, ruf mal
Anna Frebel an, wie viel Luftpolsterfolie braucht
man, um den Mars
abzuwerfen und
das Mikrofon, unsere Sennheiser-Mikrofone
überleben. Idee, Heliumpolsterfolie, damit es noch schneller in die Luft gezwirbelt wird, weil Helium steigt ja auf. Wie viel Luftpolster, Helium, ja Luft ist mega boring. Ist das eine Idee? Weil, ja, ich kombiniere zwei Ideen, das ist ja oft die besten Ideen, sie sind ja die Kombination von zwei Ideen. Manchmal sind es auch keine guten Ideen. Aber oft ja. Geschnittenes Brot. Zwei Konzepte, die schon bestanden haben. Burgerpizza. Pommendöner. Pommendöner, ja. Nicht gut. Perfekt. Musical. Musik trifft Theater. Schokoladenpizza. Ja. Hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Schokoladenkuchen. Schokolade und Kuchen. Nutella, Crepe. Nutella und Crepe. Perfekt. Ist streng genommen eine Idee, aber gut. Also Nasenbär. Ja, so. Und jetzt, alle Leute lieben es diese Luftfeuchtfolie, Luftpolsterfolie aufzupoppen. Zu dröseln. Und Leute lieben Helium wegen der hohen Stimme. So kommen übrigens Aliens auch anloggen auf dem Mars. Ein bisschen Luftpolsterfolie. Mir kann keiner erzählen, dass die denen widerstehen können, die so kaputt zu machen. Das kann schon sein. Habt ihr unsere Luftpolster-Fulli dabei? Ja, aber wir haben die schon aufgepoppt. Zu gezirbelt. Bisschen gezirbelt. Oder die Aliens kommen extra auf unsere Erde, um uns die Luftpolster-Fulli wieder zurückzunehmen. Ihr habt ja einen Scheissmüll hier! Dann fahren sie wieder Ja genau, es kommen so Roboter, wo ist euer Anführer? Und dann so, nein, was wollt ihr? Wollt ihr uns alle besiegen und umbringen? Luftpolsterfolie. Und jetzt die Kombination Helium, also Luftpolsterfolie mit Helium, aber in so Dropgröße. Du kannst es wie so eine Tablette essen. Worüber reden wir gerade noch mal? Heliumtabletten, Helium Luftpolster, Helium Luftpolster. Wofür? Dass du die aufpoppen kannst, Spaß, erster Spaß, und dann hast du auch noch eine hohe Stimme, zweiter Spaß. Du kriegst doppelten Spaß. Das ist perfekt. Doppelspaß. Das ist wirklich perfekt. Jedenfalls dachte ich dann, bei diesen ganzen Stages, die diese Landung hatte, du willst ja nicht, auf keinen Fall willst du das Department sein, was es verkackt. Ja, ja. Das ist unangenehm, weil du willst, das Fallschirm-Department ist eh schon die Kackfarbe ausgesucht, rot-weiss kariert. Alle sind unzufrieden mit rot-weiss kariert. Alle sind eh schon unzufrieden mit uns. Es ist einer dieser Kompromisse, wo am Ende alle unzufrieden sind. Es gibt nicht mal einen, der zufrieden ist. Und wie ist es in der letzten Reihe von diesem NASA Control Room, wo man eh sich fragt, hätten wir es nicht im Homeoffice machen können? Warum sitzen wir jetzt alle, wir können eh nichts mehr machen. Der ist literally am Mars. Was sollen wir denn jetzt hier rumsitzen? Weil wenn es nicht funktioniert, was soll man denn machen? Ja, im Grunde ist man auch im Homeoffice, wenn man in der NASA sitzt. Ja. Der Workplace ist der Mars. Du bist schon im Homeoffice. Du bist eh am Homeoffice. Homeplanet, Planet Office. Ja, und dann, ja, was willst du dann machen? Und willst du nicht das sein, wo dann alle Systeme am einen Fall funktioniert, aber der Fallschirm war nicht ausgelöst. Ja. Oh, fuck, so sorry. Aber sagen die eigentlich auch so einen fetzigen, also es muss ja bei der NASA auch Autoren geben, die dann sich überlegen, weil One Small Step for Man, One Giant Leap for Humankind, das hat ja jemand geschrieben. Oder meinst du da halt, oder hier Neil Armstrong? Ja, wirklich. Er war extrem nervös. Du hast auch kurz an den Radfahrer gedacht, aber du hast den richtigen. in den Trompeter. Extrem nervös, weil klar, wieder die Szene, Take-off, 10, 9, 8, ja. Leute, habt ihr eine Idee, was ich sagen könnte, wenn ich auf die Mondoberfläche gehe? Es ist nämlich wie zu den Rocket Beans fahren und sich so eine Catch-Race überlegen. Genau, niemand überlegt, bevor man ins Auto einsteigt, gibt's dieses Problem nicht. Und dann ist es sehr akut. Genau, dann ist das grösste Problem, dass du hast. Einfach so fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich dachte vielleicht irgendwie so ... Ich hab einen ... Wie du hast einen? Ich hab einen Spruch. Jetzt schon, so schnell, oder was? Für den Fall ist der Erste, bin ich am Spruch. Ja, aber wir hatten ja eigentlich gesagt, dass ich als erstes rausgehe.
Ja, gut, dann bitte.
Und dann bin ich mal gespannt auf deinen Spruch, den alle hören, live, im Fernsehen.
Sechs Milliarden Menschen.
Dann brauchst du ja deinen Spruch nicht, dann kann ich ja deinen Spruch nehmen.
Falls für den Fall, dass ich da raus muss.
Was heißt für den Fall, ich werde definitiv zuerst rausgehen und dann ... Das ist schon ein großer Schritt für dich, ne? Ja, äh, großer Schritt. Wie wär's mit Chabawabba, ich bin auf dem Mond, schaut mich an. Fickt euch alle, ich bin auf dem Mond. Fickt euch alle, ich nehm jetzt meinen Helm ab, mir scheißegal. Das wäre doch was. Wäre das gut?
Ja, finde ich super, ja. Okay.
Ja, dann mache ich das. Mach mal.
Und der Dritte einfach so, Leute, ich versuche jetzt zu kaffen.
Ich wollte dir sehr genervt.
Der, der die Kamera halten muss.
Ja. Wer war das?
Nee, gab es nicht. Stanley Kubrick. Nee, die hatten Ausnahmen am Fahrzeugkameras. Stanley Kubrick. Aber haben diese Rover auch so eine Art MP3, die sie abspielen, wenn die da auf dem Mars landen? Weil es gibt ja die drei Autoren, die irgendwie dann so ein 30-Rock-T-Shirt anhaben und irgendwie so eine Homer-Simpsons-Mütze auf, irgendwie so die drei Lustigen bei der NASA, die halt dann hinten sitzen und dann halt sich auch denken, ja so gut war der Gag nicht, den wir jetzt da abgeschickt haben an die MP3-Abteilung. Ich meine, das hat irgendwie Steve Carell eingesprochen. Aber der Gag war nicht so cool, dass er da war. Aber der G Gang war nicht so gut. Cool, dass er da war. Cool, dass er da war. Aber der Gang war nicht so gut. Aber haben die gar keinen Catchphrase? Die hatten keinen Catchphrase. Was sie hatten wiederum ist einen Twitter-Kanal. Perseverance hat einen Twitter-Kanal, den kann ich nur allen ans Herz legen. Da kommen cool Bilder jeden Tag. Perseverance vielleicht. Perseverance, so könnt ihr die doch heißen. Das ist wie so ein unsympathischer Highschool-Bulli. Perseverance. Oh nein, es ist Perseverance. Nein, da kommt Perseverance. Und er fragt Jessica. Nein, er fragt Jessica, ob sie zusammen zum Ball gehen. Und Jessica freut sich und sagt ja. Fuck, ich hatte ... Er kommt auf uns zu.
Na, ihr lutschen!
Ich bin so gegen den Spind geschlagen.
Klasse, Percy.
In den Mülleimer gesteckt.
Also, NASA Perseverance Mars Rover.
Und der hat den süssesten Tweet aller Zeiten abgesetzt,
als er gelandet ist.
Er hat geschrieben, äh, das ist ein erstes Bild
von meinem Forever Home. Ich bin gerade gelandet, alles gut gelaufen, gute Reise gehabt, hier ist ein Bild, ein erster Eindruck von meinem Forever Home. Und ich war so traurig über mein Forever Home, weil ich dachte, ja klar, wir haben den da hingeschickt zum Sterben. Eigentlich schon, ja. Und dann hat aber ein Kumpel von mir gesagt, aber wir sind auch, die Erde ist unser Forever Home. Und dann hatte ich einen Mental Breakdown. Weil ehrlich gesagt, das stimmt ja. Ich war so traurig. Nicht notwendigerweise, wir können ja auch auf dem Mars fliegen. Wir werden noch auf dem Mars. Dann sind wir forever dead. Dead, dead. Sind wir dann schwanger auf dem Mars oder was? Ist das unser Spin-off?
Nee, wir sind forever dead. Ach so, aber ich meine, ich glaube, wir werden noch auf dem Mars fliegen, wir beide. Wir beide werden noch auf dem Mars fliegen? Wegen Podcast-Ufo? Ja, natürlich, das bietet sich doch an. Sobald die ESA sagt, wir haben hier Tickets, die werden eh hochschicken, irgendwie zwei Krebskranke, zwei Influencer und uns beiden werden die in die erste Kapsel schicken. Meinst du vielleicht, weil es heißt ja immer, dass Astronauten, also das bemannte Mars-Mission auch gefährlich ist, weil die Menschen an dem Lagerkoller leiden könnten. Glaubst du, dass wir beiden dann vielleicht dazugeholt werden, um die Stimmung aufzulockern? Ja, ist das eine Menge Verantwortung. Oder kriegen wir dann untereinander Lagerkoller und einer von uns bringt den anderen um? Ich finde, wir sollten zur Sicherheit acht Staffeln OC California in der Hinterhand haben, falls irgendwie unsere Flugdecker-Gribbik, wir haben Flugdecker-Gribbik nicht gesehen. Oh mein Fuck. Gut, wir haben jetzt acht Jahre oder wie auch immer die Zeit eintragen. California, California, here we go. Hört man dann so über so einen DVD-Player, während das Schiff so langsam wegfliegt. Genau, im ESA-Hautquartier dröhnt es durch die Lautsprecher und einer drückt beschämt auf Mute. Es war ein Fehler, es war ein Fehler. Und dann sind so Leute in der letzten Reihe, die sich für uns entschieden haben und sagen, we're so sorry. Und der Parachute ist blau-weiss kariert. Ja, nein!
Nein!
Nee, das wäre aber ganz cool eigentlich. Auch eine gute
Sitcom eigentlich. Eine Mars-Mission
und es spielt alles in dem Raumschiff.
Und es geht nicht
darum, dass sie ankommen, es geht nicht
um irgendeine Technikschüssel oder so Sci-Fi-Kram,
einfach nur wie die
in der Freizeit, halt so wie How I Met Your Mother. Da geht es ja auch nicht darum, um die Jobs, die die haben. Die haben ja noch normale Jobs dann, ne? Ja, aber man kommt ja zu dem Zeitpunkt in die Serie rein, wo die dann in der Barabend sitzen. Und ich will quasi eine Sitcom über eine bemannte Mars-Mission, wo da gibt es einen Funny Guy, da gibt es einen Tech-Girl, da gibt's einen, weiss ich nicht, Chef. Der Vergessliche. Der Vergessliche, der sagt, ah fuck, ich hab meinen Kohlschreiber auf der Erde vergessen. Ja, weil er im Zimmer schläft mit dem Mono, wie heißt das, wo man vergisst, Kohlenmonoxid, mit dem Kohlenmonoxid. Wie cool ist das denn? Wie heißt das Gas, wo man alles vergisst? Wie heißt das Gas, wo man alles... Du brauchst halt nur so einen Praktikanten, der alle drei Minuten gegen die Kulisse schlägt, damit alles vibriert, damit alle wissen, dass sie noch in einem Raumschiff sind. Aber ansonsten... Ich finde das super. Ist das eine gute Show? Ich finde das eine super Show, super geil, einfach zu produzieren. Guck mal, aber da haben wir es doch jetzt. Fernsehshow, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Sie wurden ausgewählt, die erste bemannte Mars-Mission. Sie dürfen mitfliegen. Das ist ein Prank. Und die kommen alle in Raum. Und Thais klopft da alle paar Minuten gegen die Tür, damit die denken, sie sind tatsächlich unterwegs. Hätte ich so eine Freund. Und dann müssen die da ein Jahr drin sein und nach einem Jahr versteckte Kamera geht die Tür auf und sie sind halt immer noch auf der Erde und sagen, it's a prank. Und die so, hä? Hä? Ist doch ganz gut. Vielleicht, muss man dann gucken, was dann passiert. Aber dann tut man so und dann irgendwie, oh, Sauerstoffleck oder so und dann irgendwie so Katastrophen. Und dann guckt man mal, wie weit die gehen würden. Und wenn die sagen, einer muss gegessen werden, dann muss man abbrechen. Bisschen wie Big Brother, nur halt in krasser Scale. Ja. Oh, ich finde das super. Super. Das ist eine gute Idee, ne? Aber grenzt auch ab. Oh mein Gott, ich bin ganz doll ins Kabel gekommen von allem hier. Also die Sendung ging gerade am seidenen Faden. Kannst du kurz gucken, ob noch alles geht? Ja, alles gut. Also, das heißt, man muss halt nur so den Start realistisch machen, dass die einmal so in den Sitz gedrückt werden oder so. Ja, schon noch davor so ein bisschen Medienereignis. Ja, klar. Die Journalisten dürfen nicht stehen mit, was stellen Sie sich denn vor, was wird auch im Mass sein. Also das dürfen die nicht machen. Nee, das stimmt. Die müssen schon irgendwie cool sein oder ich weiß nicht, wen man da alles verarschen muss. Ich glaube, alle in der Kette müssen eigentlich wirklich denken. Oder du sagst denen von Anfang an, nee, die müssen ja auch so ein körperliches Training durchlaufen. Und dann sagt man denen, damit wir schon mal testen können, ob sie mental in der Isolation leben können, sind sie jetzt in dieser Trainingsinstitut und sie sind komplett von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten. Damit wir schon mal testen können, ob sie dem mental standhalten können. Und dann kann man denen sagen, Leute, da draußen ist ein riesen Medienspektakel, das zeigen wir euch aber nicht, weil sie müssen in Isolation leben, um sich dran zu fühlen. Trotzdem müsst ihr diesen Zettel unterschreiben und eure Rechte abtreten. Hier steht aber RTL drauf. Ach so, nee, dieses Formular. Ach so, aha. Und dann kann man erklären, warum die das Medienspektakel nicht mitbekommen, das ist alles geheim. Ja. Und dann halt einmal in den Sitz gedrückt werden, vielleicht wenn die so Helme aufhaben, dass sie nichts sehen dürfen, im Sinne von sonst fallen ihre Augen raus. Und dann kommen Praktikanten in den Raum und drücken die so mit den Händen in die Sitze. Also Thais drückt alle in den Sitz. Thais drückt zwei in den Sitz und dann merken die, oh, das ist schon krass. Und dann muss die schnell wieder raus und dann geht das Licht an, ihr dürft jetzt die Helme absetzen. Und dann ist erst mal so. Sagt Micky Beisenherz, das dann über die Lautsprecher. Genau, und dann erst mal 50 Wochen ist das Experiment angelegt. Ja. Und dann guckt man, was passiert. Und es läuft so Truman Show einfach jeden Abend im Fernsehen. Da kann man dann reinzappen bei RTL. Ja, so eine Zusammenfassung, ja. War nämlich doch RTL. Und dann macht man es
an und dann läuft dann das in so eine Zusammenfassung,
was heute wieder Lustiges aus unserem Mars-Shuttle passiert ist. Ja. Ach, finde ich das geil. Das wäre ein Ereignis. Kann man aber rauswählen und dann geht so ein Luke auf Aber ist die Frage, ist es verboten, Leute zu belügen?
Ja, dann hätte Frank Elstner und Guido Keinz hätten ein Riesenproblem. Ja, das stimmt. Das versteht sich Spaß. Ja, an einem gewissen Punkt ist es, glaube ich, Freiheitsberaubung. Also, wenn die ja aktiv ... Wir können die nicht einschweren. Nee, aber da kann man ja unterschreiben, weil wenn die zum Mars fliegen, dann dürfen die auch nicht aus dem Flugzeug raus oder aus dem Raumschiff raus. Raumschiff. Aus dem Fahrrad raus. Warum sagen sie immer Raumschiff mit Anführungszeichen? Ja, aber du hast recht in dem Sinne, ich glaube, man müsste es irgendwo in AGBs verstecken. Das ist, glaube ich, generell der Trick für alles. Es gibt auch so Dating-Plattformen mittlerweile, wo sich dann vor allem Ältere anmelden, wo die gar nicht mehr mit einem Dating-Partner schreiben, sondern einfach mit so Leuten, die das so tun. Inder, ja. Sehr romantische Inder. Romantische Inder. Und das ist halt echt ein Problem. Oder sehr schlecht bezahlte Studenten. Aber das ist auch ein spannender Job. Auf der anderen Seite aber einfach nur wahnsinnig unbeiratet und Kacke. Das heißt, du flirtest den ganzen Tag mit Rentnern. Das ist dein Job als Student. Ja, du flirtest mit Rentnern. Und dann dachte ich mir, was ist, wenn du dich als so ein Autor, ich glaube, die heißen irgendwie ITM oder so, und was ist, wenn du dich als so jemanden verliebst in die Person, die du belügen musst? Aha. Aber dann habe ich gehört, die wechselnst du auch durch. Das heißt, du schreibst immer nur irgendwie ein bisschen mit denen. Und du wirst pro Nachricht bezahlt, die die zurückschicken. Das ist auch absurd. Das heißt aber, mehrere Leute schreiben dann mit einem Kunden sozusagen. Aber gibt es dann nicht so ein Briefing? Das gibt ein Backstory-Katalog. Das sind unsere Running Gags. Meiner Erfahrung nach läuft Flirten primär über Running Gags einfach. Ein Running Gag. Es ist einfach humoristische Geiselname, einfach immer wieder denselben Gag zu machen. Aber es funktioniert, man kommt nicht mehr raus. Das heißt, du musst dann immer so ein Briefing übergeben, ja, wir haben viele Gags über Werters Original gemacht, viele Gags über Schwiegertöchter und bitte. Ja, du hast rechts wohl angeblich so eine Backstory stehen. Du hast gesagt, du hast eine Tochter schon, du hast gesagt, die wohnt in Oldenburg, heisst Nora, hieß aber auch schon mal Mara. Das ist so ein bisschen ein Problem gewesen. Du hast halt die ganze Backstory so rechts stehen. Eigentlich, ja, ich finde den Job zu spannend, aber er ist halt einfach wahnsinnig. Ja, natürlich, ist ja klar. Ist ja klar. Aber das ist so ein bisschen so. Wie, wo, wie klar haben wir das? Ne, so wie das, also das ist halt das Problem,, wenn Curiosity ins Tinder aufmacht, hat er halt einen Vorschlag, Perseverance, und dann so, keine weiteren Vorschläge. Da hätte er den Kopf so hängen. Alle sehen auch ein bisschen aus wie Wall-E. Ja, und Perseverance sagt aber, ich habe dich gerideswiped. Klar, weil Perseverance ist ja darauf bedacht. Ja, Perseverance kommt mit einem riesen Blumenstrauss. Er hält's durch. Perseverance bleibt halt am Ball. Bleibt dran. Und Curiosity hat aber, ich glaub, die sind ein Match, ganz ehrlich. Ich glaub, Perseverance und Curiosity sind ein Match. Curiosity ist viel zu curious. Und Perseverance ist halt so, ja, zu hartnäckig. Zu hartnäckig, gibt halt nicht auf. Kann man dann doch sagen. Das stimmt schon. Gibt nicht auf. Und dann hat sie noch die Drohne dabei, Ingenuity. Aber das ist schon unangenehm, wenn man zu dritt auf einem Planeten ist. Und du weißt, einer wird übrig bleiben. Einer wird übrig bleiben. Warum eigentlich? Warum sagst du das immer, Perseverance? Und warum, glaube ich, bist du das? Also ich bin gespannt, was da noch passiert, aber gehört denen jetzt der Mars eigentlich, wenn die da leben? Uns, würde ich sagen. Uns als Amerikanern gehört jetzt der Mars. Okay, gut, alles klar. Haben die auch so eine Fahne da reingerammt? Oder haben die Roboter so eine Robofahne? Die haben dann so einen QR-Code da reingefahren in die Oberfläche. Einfach so biebubieb biebubieb biebubieb. Der Mars ist unser. Nicht der beste Planet. Nee. Ich bin nicht so ein riesiger Mars-Fan. Ich wäre als Venus auch super pisst, dass jetzt mittlerweile schon drei Roboter anscheinend auf dem Mars sind und heil niemand bei mir. Niemand bei mir. Ich habe riesige Schwefelhügel. Gut, ich bin aus Gas. Ich bin ein Riesengasgerücken. Aber ich habe hier auch so riesige Schwefelblasen dabei. Ich habe hier so ein Methanmeer, in dem Leute baden können. Keine Spur von Leben. Null, aber nicht im Ansatz. Null. Nicht im Ansatz. Mir war noch nie was, mir wird nie was sein. Aber jetzt mich darzustellen, als ob das jetzt... Nee, ich finde, ich habe was zu bieten. Helium, Höhlen. Und rast die Venus nicht einfach nur immer so um die Sonne? Ist das nicht so? Ich glaube, das ist die Definition von jedem Planeten, glaube ich. Nee, die rast sie besonders schnell. Die schnell? Die RAS ist schneller. Doch, ich glaube schon. Und Leute versuchen, sie aufzuhalten. Aber geht nicht. Venus ist ja so nah an der Sonne, dass sie nicht draufprallt, heißt ja, dass sie ultra, ultra schnell ist, damit die sich ausgleichen, die Anziehungskraft der Sonne, der Zentipitalkraft. Oh, das war das Clevers. Oh, du bist so schlau. Ich kann mir Podcast eher unentwickelt. Du bist so schlau. Aber mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unsere Neun. Ja, auch wegen diesem dummen Spruch habe ich das Nerdquiz verloren. Die letzte Frage war, was ist der dritte Planet von der Sonne entfernt? Und ich habe komplett gechokt, nichts. Pluto. Das Problem ist ja, du hast ja ganz viele von diesen Merksprüchen, dieses Geh du alter Esel hol Fische, frische Brezen, Quintenzirke, frische Brezen, Essen, Asse des Gesangs. Was war das nochmal? Quintenzirke, Fis, Fis, B, S, Ass, des Ges, so rechts rum. Mehr, mehr Sprüche. Und das ist dann halt irgendwie solche Sachen. Und dann weißt du nicht, dann war ich auch bei frische Brezen. Nee, ein alter Esel ging Honig essen. Was soll das nochmal? Das sind die Seiten der Gitarre. Ach ja, das kenne ich auch. Solche Sachen. Das heißt, das eigentliche Gute bei diesem Mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Abend meine neuen Planeten, ist gut, weil das, was es beschreibt, ist im Sprichwort drin.
Wohingegen mein Esel, nee, ein Esel.
Geh du alter Esel hoch.
Genau, geh du alter Esel hoch.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ein alter Dackel gegen Honig essen.
Genau, das sind die Seiten der Getarbe.
Das ist so, was ist das jetzt?
Sind es jetzt die Kaiser von Rom oder welcher, was ist mit Honig?
Die Honig essen. Genau, das sind die Seiten der Getarne. Ein alter Dackel gegen Honig essen. Das ist so, was ist das jetzt? Sind es jetzt die Kaiser von Rom oder welcher, was ist mit Honig, die grössten Bienenköniginnen der Welt oder was? Tierrassen, so das ist halt kompletter Bullshit, so deswegen, du weißt zu viel davon einfach. Das stimmt. Wie weit geht es eigentlich mit deinen... Ah, ist falsch, immer noch, ne? Mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unsere neun. Mann, ey, du hast jetzt einmal für eine Folge nicht vorbereitet, um schlau zu wirken. Und jetzt kommst du aber nicht mehr drumherum. Ich habe mal aufgestellt, mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unseren Nachthimmel. P fehlt, Blut ist ja kein Planet mehr, deswegen ist es flicht oder veraltet. Deswegen biete ich an, aber es hat mir auch schon mal in Folge drei oder sowas. Es wurde immer noch nicht angenommen. Wurde immer noch nicht angenommen. Mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unseren Nachthimmel. Wie läuft es eigentlich mit deinem Millennium-Problem? Bist du schon dran an dem Mathe-Problem? Hast du es schon eins angegangen, eingeteckelt? Schleppend. Sag mir so, du hast schon mal die Frage aufs Papier geschrieben. Der Weg, nicht mal das, der Weg zum Millennium-Problem im Internet ist ja gespickt von spannenden anderen Dingen. Genau, das sind diese grossen Mathe-Probleme, die wenn man sie löst, kriegt man eine Million Dollar. Und ich glaube, der Einzige, der bis jetzt eins gelöst hat, hat diese eine Million Dollar abgelehnt. So, genau. Was halt ein ziemlich badass-Move. Das ist halt schon ziemlich cool. Also sind es gespendet?
Nee, abgelehnt.
Ich würde jetzt, lass uns, also,
okay, weil wir machen das ja bald.
Ey, im Podcast-Ufo wird eh nächste Zeit wird dir grosser, ja, Cash.
unfassbar coole Sachen werden passieren.
Cash. Ich sag mal so,
es ist so cool, ein Podcast-Ufo-Fan gerade
zu sein. Podcast-Hörer reicht ja
auch, weil dir passieren coole Sachen. Unter anderem, ja. Beobachter, weil unter anderem haben wir ja vor, ein Millennium-Problem zu lösen. Wir machen ja die große, das Podcast-Ufo-Millennium-Marathon. Ja genau. Und die Folge ist so lang, wie es dauert, das Problem zu lösen. Wir schlafen nicht, wir schlafen nicht, wir setzen es als Millennium-Problem so lange, bis wir es gelöst haben. Aber maximal eine Stunde, okay? Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Und wenn wir gewinnen, dann lehnen wir... Nee, wir legen es alles auf Rot. Das ist auch badass. Wir nehmen an und lesen alles auf Rot. Nein! Das ist badass. Eine Million auf Rot, das heißt, du gewinnst zwei Millionen, wenn du gewinnst. Oder das Casino, oder MGM Grand gewinnt halt. Was ein grosser Bildschwuss. Ich meine, wir machen das, wir lösen so ein Millennium-Problem und dann ist es nichts anderes, als würden wir die Millionen spenden in das Bellagio. Genau, wir setzen es erst bei Roulette und wenn wir verlieren, sagen wir, ja, wir spenden es ihnen. Wir spenden es ihnen. Aber ich glaube, es ist ein grösserer Shitstorm, das an das MGM Grand zu spenden, als es einfacher zu verlieren, ehrlich. Das finde ich ja cool. Aber was machen wir? Wir bitten uns mal in einer der nächsten Folgen die Millennium-Probleme. Ja, es gibt ein paar interessante Millennium-Probleme, die sind halt super abstrakt und super abgefahren. Das ist dein Satz? Es gibt ein paar interessante Millennium-Probleme. Die sind halt super abstrakt, weil man denkt, oh, Mathe-Problem, wie schwer wird das sein, halt Wurzel von zehn, ja, ja, ja, ich könnte die lösen, aber die sind halt super strange. Mehr als drei, aber weniger als vier. Ja, das ist die Näherung. Aber das ist so, die Matheprobleme sind ja oft so, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Quadrat ein Quadrat ist? So, und man sagt, ja, wir sind uns ziemlich sicher, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Nähe von hundert Prozent liegt, aber es würde noch nicht bewiesen, dass es genau hundert Prozent ist. Das ist eine Frage, wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Quadrat ein Quadrat ist? Und jetzt ist die Frage... Ist es so Multiple-Choice? Bitte. Das sind leider keine Multiple-Choice-Fragen. Und also, es ist dann A, 100 Prozent ... So ein Millennium-Problem, ein glössiges, warte mal, dinges Problem. Aber, hä, woher wir dann die Antworten mögen? B, 200 Prozent. Ja, ich kann dir ... Ja, mach erst mal C. Wir wissen, dass es irgendwo zwischen 99,9 und 100 Prozent liegt. Kann man denn irgendwo so Joker nehmen? Es gibt einen Publikumsjoker. Nee, gibt es einen Mathematiker-Joker. Einfach keine fucking Ahnung. Wir haben halt keine Ahnung. So ist es Fragezeichen. Und du kannst deinen Onkel anrufen, wenn du willst. Wir würden dann nämlich, wenn wir dieses Problem uns vorknöpfen, dann ... An, ja oder angehen, würden wir uns dann nämlich auch einen Mathematiker vorknöpfen. Okay, ja okay, aber was ist, wenn dann, wenn der es löst und wir halt eher so dabei gewesen sind, auch cool und halt eher so am Buffet rumgelungert haben, während er am Laptop sitzt und halt das Ding ausklamüsert. Auch coole Folge trotzdem, coole Folge.
Wir sind halt am Buffet und reden darüber,
ist es schon mal aufgefallen, dass bei Shrimps immer eine gerade Zahl ist.
Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Shrimps-Buffet eine gerade Anzahl Shrimps beinhaltet?
A. Annähernd 100 %,, B annähernd 0 Prozent, C ist mir egal. Ich sag mal so, nachdem du da warst, hattest Shrimps Buffet eh null Shrimps. Da musst du mir erst mal sagen, ob null gerade oder ungerade ist. Ba-bam! Könnt ihr bitte ein bisschen leiser sein, ich versuche hier zu arbeiten an eurem Millennium-Problem.
Sorry.
Entschuldigung.
Oder D.
Sollen wir die Tür zumachen?
Ja.
Wir schieben ihm trotzdem so langsam so ein Mikrofon hin.
So eine ganz lange, so eine ganz lange Angel.
Das wird auf jeden Fall ein Ding.
Und wir wollen eine Brücke bauen.
Also wir haben gesagt, wir wollen eine riesige Brücke bauen über die Elbe. Einmal rüber und wieder zurück. Das ist so eine U-Turn-Brücke. Einmal rüber und wieder zurück. Also falls ihr irgendwie Metall abzahlt habt. Aber so gebaut, dass man niemals auf der anderen Seite ankommen kann, sondern die gehen direkt wieder zurück.
Das ist eigentlich ein cooles Kunstwerk.
Ja, wir haben ja keinen öffentlichen Auftrag, wir machen das ja aus Scheiß.
Und also falls ihr Metall zuhause rumliegen habt, schickt es gerne an uns, wir sammeln Sachen und bauen dann daraus eine riesige Brücke, die einmal so auch ganz, die eher so einen Halbkreis hat, also die einmal so ganz steil nach oben geht und auf der anderen Seite wieder runter und dann aber die Wände. Rutschenartig runter geht. Rutschenartig. Also das ist auch noch ein Projekt. Also wir nicht ein Problem lösen, wir wollen eine riesige Brücke bauen. Und dann und andere Sachen. Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall ein paar Sachen vor, weil ich habe jetzt nicht mehr so viel zu tun, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Also die nächsten, jetzt sind noch ein paar Termine, danach habe ich erstmal nichts mehr zu tun und dann machen wir mal crazy shit, Podcast Ufo wird insane.
Ich hätte mal Lust, so ein Loch zu graben und mich da reinzulegen.
Ja, die Lochfolge, die grosse Lochfolge, wo wir dann nicht mehr eingraben. 309 Loch.
Loch, wo wir nicht mehr eingraben.
Ich glaube, das ist angenehm kühl.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Willst du dein Köpfchen noch rausgucken oder bis wohin soll ich eingraben?
Nö, muss nicht.
Doch, klar, zum Atmen, Atmen, hallo.
Nee, nee, aber versuchen sich nicht auch Vögel manchmal so einzugraben im Boden, wenn den warm ist?
Storche, nee, Vogelsträuße, die den Kopf in den Sand stecken.
Nein, ich meine Vögel, die sich im Boden nicht... Ich hab's gleich. Du bist so angestrengt. Vögel, die so versuchen, sich einzugraben in Sand, um sich abzukühlen. Warum macht der Mensch das nicht? Der einzige Grund, warum sich Menschen auf dem Boden wälzen, ist, wenn sie in Flammen stehen. Und da sage ich, ist es wirklich... Oder Wrestling. Oder Wrestling, gut, Wrestling. Sind es wirklich die beiden einzigen Anlässe, zu denen wir uns auf dem Boden wälzen sollen, oder gibt es nicht noch viele andere innovative Anlässe, sich auf dem Boden zu wälzen? Sollten wir das nicht viel häufiger machen? Das ist meine Frage an dich.
Gute Frage an mich. Ich würde sagen, also generell Sand, sich in Sand zu eingraben oder sowas ist immer cool, aufgetan. Wie so eine Krabbe, ja, ja.
Und häufig schon gemacht, ehrlich gesagt, als Kind. Kinder graben sich ein.
Kinder neigen, menschliche Kinder, das würden auch so Aliens in so einer Schule lernen, menschliche Kinder neigen sich dazu, am Strand sich einzugraben und diese kleinen Dinge zu bauen. Warum sie es tun, wissen wir nicht. A, das ist ein Millennium-Problem. Warum graben sich Menschlinge, so werden die Menschen genannt, Menschlinge im Sand ein? A, sie denken, sie wären ein Baum und könnten wachsen. Können sie vielleicht, wissen wir nicht. B, graben nach Gold. C, ihnen ist warm. Zu warm, das haben wir gehört, dass sie sagen, heute ist es aber warm. Heiss, heiß, heiß. Puh, puh, puh, puh. Ich bin ganz schön durchgeschwitzt. Ja, ich schwitze kaputt. Oder D. Oder D. Sie möchten gerne eine Krabbe sein. Aber können es nicht, weil sie ein Menschling sind. Ich habe damals, ich weiß noch, ich habe als Kind eine Radioshow gemacht. Ich hatte eine Radioshow bei Bayern 3. Was? Nein, ich habe auf alte Bibli-Bloxberg-Kassetten meine Stimme aufgenommen und das war eine Radioshow. Das sage ich immer allen, wenn man mich fragt, warum ich talentiert bin. Es kommt manchmal lustigerweise... Das wurdest du schon so oft gefragt, dass du dir da eine Standardantwort, eine vorgefertigte Antwort dafür zurechtlegen musst. Das ist gar nicht arrogant gemeint, aber ich habe im relativ jungen Jahr ist man ja zu der Netflix-Serie gekommen und da kam dann häufig die Frage, warum ich so talentiert bin und so ein Scheiß oder was Talent für mich bedeutet und keine Ahnung was.
Und da sage ich dann immer, dass ich an Talent nicht glaube.
Zum Beispiel mein Podcast-Ufo-Komoderator, der Florentin Will, der ist ja nicht einfach nur talentiert,
sondern der hat als Kind ja schon angefangen, seine Radioshow aufzunehmen.
Das stimmt, ja. Und deswegen ist er besonders gut darin. Ja, ich sag mal so, die Show hatte Schwächen. Natürlich hat sie Schwächen, aber du hast ja natürlich wahnsinnig, du hast ja mittlerweile die tausend Stunden, aber mal dreimal voll. Ja, die Show war damals nicht so gut, weil ich habe oft Infosendungen gemacht über Themen, mit denen ich mich nicht auskenne. So viel hat sich gar nicht geändert tatsächlich. Das stimmt.
Damals kam ja der Euro, da war das Top-Thema natürlich, der Euro kommt.
Und dann habe ich eine Infosendung gemacht mit Anrufern.
Hattest du einen Experten?
Nein, ich als Moderator war der Experte, ich hatte Anrufer,
aka mein Cousin, der deine Stimme verstellt hat.
Der Cousin?
Mein Cousin, der hat seine Stimme verstellt und angerufen.
Warum hat er seine Stimme verstellt? Weil er vorher auch schon anderen Experten gespielt hat?
Ja, weil er hat verschiedene Anrufer gespielt. Paid Actor. Genau, und dann habe ich erklärt, wie das funktioniert mit dem Euro. Und aus irgendeinem Grund wusste ich aber nicht, wie der hundertste Teil von einem Euro heißt, wie die Unterkategorie sozusagen heißt. Ich habe aber trotzdem eine Infosendung gemacht und ich rede in dieser gesamten Infosendung darüber, dass ein Euro besteht aus 100-Euro-Lingen. Also ich wusste nicht, dass es Cent heißt, sondern habe einfach Euro-Linge gesagt und dann, ach so, und dann kostet das dann nicht mehr eine Mark, sondern 50-Euro-Linge. Aha, ja. Und die gesamte Sendung ist so und sich denkt, was ist das für ein Experte? Nicht gut gealtert. Überhaupt nicht gut gealtert, der die ganze Zeit
Eurolinge sagt. Aber
ich habe es durchgezogen. Aber jetzt wurde die Währung
ja irgendwann erfunden.
Ja, genau. Und dann wurde ja irgendwann auch überlegt,
was ist denn der Bruchteil? Genau, und die haben sich
leider gegen Eurolinge entschieden.
Wir würden heute in einer anderen Welt leben.
Würden wir, aber warum hat man das denn für Cent entschieden?
Wo kommt denn Cent her eigentlich? Ja, von 100
oder so? Ah ja. Centus?
Centner. Centner?
Sowas? Cent. Aber da muss
und Würden wir, aber warum hat man das denn für Cent entschieden? Wo kommt denn Cent her eigentlich? Ja, von hundert oder so? Ah ja. Centus? Centner. Centner? Sowas? Cent, aber da muss es ja irgendwie, das ist die Ethnologie von Cent. Ganz kurz, das finden wir nämlich jetzt raus, weil anders als damals hast du jetzt Internet. Hundertling, Hunni, Hund? Ich glaube schon von Cent. Centurio ist doch auch der, der 100 Leute hat. Centurion. Centner weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, aber kann schon auch sein. Aber ja, das waren meine ersten Schritte in Inkompetenz, in öffentliche Inkompetenz und ja. Oh, in den Sprachen der meisten Euroländer existieren für den Cent eigene Bezeichnungen. In Deutschland Euro-Linge? Nein. In Frankreich, Griechenland, Malta, den Niederlanden, Slowenien und Zypern entsprechen sie den Namen der kleinen Einheiten, die dort direkt vor der Einführung des Euros in Gebrauch waren. Also bei uns wäre es noch Pfennig. Wir haben aber dann den Cent aufgegriffen, hätten uns aber genauso gut dann offensichtlich für Euro-Linge entscheiden können. Eigentlich schon, ja. Der Name kommt vom lateinischen Centum, Kentum, 100, vermutlich aus dem niederländischen und englischen ins deutsche vermittelt. Plural und jentiform ist Centz, für mehrere Münzen an sich und Cent für die Wertangabe. Und wieder war es dazugelernt. Es ist aber noch nicht vorbei. Also wir könnten jetzt als Kollektive, also ich glaube, das ist eines der wichtigsten Projekte der Neuzeit, ist Centents zu ändern in Euro-Linge, dass wir da einfach wieder irgendwie auf die richtige Gerade kommen. Mein Vorschlag ist Eurochen. Gut, dann haben wir hier zwei, dann müssen wir uns hier spalten, zwei Bewegungen, die Bewegung spaltet sich nochmal. Ja, die eh schon kleine Splitterbewegung spaltet sich nochmal auf. Nachdem wir eigentlich angefangen haben, als Bewegung die Caps-Lock-Taste abzuschaffen, haben wir uns abgespaltet, als wir wollen den Cent ändern und jetzt noch mal aufgespaltet in Eurochen und Eurolinge. Also ja, das ist auch das Problem übrigens an Splitterparteien, dass sie sich immer wieder aufsplitten, weil die auch nicht genau wissen, was sie wollen. Was ist mit Eurolinchen? Raus! Ach so, du erhältst dich für einiges Vereinzahlen! Weg vom Buffet! Bernhard, weg von den Shrimps! Sind eh keine Männer! Shrimplinge. Eurochen. Ein Shrimp. Sind hundert Shrimplinge, okay? Niemals! Nur bei der Leiche. Cent klingt auch schon kleiner als Euro, aber kann auch sein, dass man es mittlerweile gelernt. Ja, Eurochen wäre mein Vorschlag. Ein Euro, hundert Eurochen. Es wird dann ein Euro, zwölf Eurochen. Süss. Hättest du nicht auch mal Lust, was wirklich, also Teil einer Bewegung zu sein? Oder hast du Angst, dass du dann irgendwie die falschen, du dann in die falsche Bewegung dich eingliederst und dann die Geschichte dich abstraft? Ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor Bewegungen, weil Bewegung sagt ja schon, gibt ja was mit so Richtungen. Man weiss dann eben offensichtlich, welche Richtung man geht, ob die Richtung die richtige ist. Deswegen finde ich erst mal gut, an seinem Ort zu bleiben. Aber natürlich habe ich schon ich schon oft darüber nachgedacht, meiner Bewegung beizutreten oder einer anzuführen oder sowas. Gerade wir, die als visionäre Köpfe hier ab und zu auf Ideen kommen. Deswegen dachte ich mir auch schon häufig, das mal zu machen. Aber man hat natürlich auch oft nicht in einem Griff, wer dann so mit dabei ist noch. Also da fehlen ja irgendwann Leute dazu und dann muss man die ja für die ja auch noch bürgen.
Ja, okay, dann Regel, jeder darf nur Mitglied in einer Bewegung sein.
Du kannst nicht gleichzeitig in der Bring den Mac Rip zurück Gruppe Bewegung sein. Ja, Pringlescans müssen weiter werden.
Genau, und in der Schaff die Caps Lock Taste ab. Du musst dich entscheiden.
Und dann hast du nicht das Problem, dass du sagst, Moment mal, haben wir hier, nennt den Filet-O-Fisch wieder in den Fischmeck um Leute unter uns? Nein, nein. Okay, so dann hast du nicht die Gefahr, dass die Gruppen sich vermischen. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei SchülerVZ, das ist das SchülerVZ-Problem oder StudiVZ-Problem, da konnte man doch irgendwann diesen Gruppen beitreten, weißt du das noch? Warst du da jemals? Ne, ich war da nie. Da konnte man irgendwann diesen
Gruppen da beitreten, hast du quasi in deinem Profil,
wolltest einfach lustige Gespräche stehen haben, dann bist du in der Gruppe gewesen,
aber wieso konnte Spongebob unter Wasser
Feuer machen? Und dann war ich in der Gruppe,
warum konnte Spongebob unter Wasser Feuer machen?
War aber auch noch in 50 anderen Gruppen drin, die lustige Namen
hatten, da hatten alle so Gruppen dann immer
und sie lustig sind. Ja, aber
das ist genau das, das ist nämlich das Problem, weil
man, warum diese kleinen
Gruppen nicht funktionieren.
Weil, wenn einfach
Vielen Dank. Und sie lustig sind. Ja, aber das ist genau das Problem, weil man, warum diese kleinen Gruppen nicht funktionieren. Weil wenn einfach alle jetzt wirklich der Meinung sind, Pringlescans müssen breiter werden, dann kommt doch bitte alle mal einmal zusammen. Ja, und dann musst du halt austreten aus der Warum sind Snickers nur so kleinen Gruppe, musst du halt danach raus, damit du dich in der neuen Bewegung abscht. So, aber das heisst ja nicht, dass das Snickers-Problem jetzt erstmal ad acta gelegt
wurde. Nein, wenn die Pringles-Can
weiter ist, dann mal irgendwann,
dann kann man sicher wieder dem Snickers-Problem
zuwenden. Ja, dann kann es ja wieder aufgelöst
werden als Bewegung und dann ist jeder wieder frei.
Ich meine, das ist ein sinnvolles System, du kannst ja auch nicht
Mitglied von zwei Parteien sein, das wäre ja albern.
Du kannst ja auch nicht sagen, ich bin jetzt
da und da auch. Du musst dich halt für eine Bewegung rechtfertigen. Ich habe mal gespendet für Luchse. Was? Heißt das jetzt, ich bin der Luchsboy, dass ich jetzt Fackelträger bin für die Luchsbewegung? War das das richtige Tier? Habe ich mich der richtigen Bewegung? Rettet die Luchse an? Du hast gespendet für Luchse? Ich habe gespendet für Luchse. Jetzt ist Aber eine Spende für Luchse auch irgendwie so ein Abwerten von allen anderen Tieren.
Richtig, das ist ja das Problem an der Bewegung. Aber ich möchte auch kein Opportunist sein, der sagt, spendet für alle Tiere oder ich spende jetzt 50 Euro für jedes Tier. Nee, ich will mich schon festlegen auf, lass uns erstmal die Luchse in trockene Tücher bringen, ohne genau zu wissen, was das bedeutet. Und wenn die Luchse dann irgendwie mal im Stall sind, wenn die irgendwie alle einen Job haben oder Rentenversicherung... Wenn die alle trockenen Tüchern sind... Wenn die alle Schafe im Trocknen haben, dann lass uns mal gucken, wie es den Schafen geht. Ja. Und deswegen bin ich jetzt hier halt schon festgelegt. So, weil war so eine Nummer, von wegen, eine Bekannte von mir wünscht sich zum Geburtstag kein Geschenk, sondern spinnet bitte an die Luchse. Und ich dachte mir, merkst du, wenn ich nicht an die Luchse spende? Nein. Hm. Ich könnte 50 Euro in Pringles investieren. Und da habe ich gesagt, nein, ich bin ein guter Mensch, komm, hier, nimm mein Geld. Ich weiß nicht, wo das Geld hingekommen ist, aber irgendein Luchs ist jetzt reicher. Ehrlich gesagt, aber geil, man soll ja spezifisch spenden, oder? Du meinst einen einzelnen Luchs, also ich sage, ein einzelner Luchs soll ... Ja, nee, ich fand jetzt die Unterkategorie Luchs schon sehr spezifisch. Das ist an dir schon zu spezifisch? Pfotenwesen oder was? Du siehst alles, was Pfoten hat. Zum Beispiel, Huftiere. Ich spende für Huftiere. Ist mir immer noch ein bisschen zu speziell. Wirbler. Ja, Wirbeltiere. Was ist mit den Quallen? Tiere, dessen Schnauze gemalt dem Mercedes-Stern auf dem Kopf ähmelt. Verstehst du? Diese wie Bären, Luchse, Tiger, solche Winnie the Pooh. Ja, Katzen finde ich gut, finde ich gut. Das ist wie so Fonds, die so verschiedene Gruppen von Aktien zusammenfassen. Da muss man eigentlich sagen, wir sind nur für alle die, die drei oder mehr Beine haben. Aber wir haben kein fucking Bock auf Strauße. Auf gar keinen fucking Fall sehen die auch nur einen einzigen Cent. Nichts. Die sehen kein Eurochen jemals. Da gibt es auch eine Splitterpartei, die dann wiederum sagt, wir sind drei plus Beine plus Drausse.
Die machen dann die Ausnahmen und nehmen die auch noch dazu.
Aber das ist schwierig, das ist wirklich schwierig.
Es ist schwierig.
Du hast schon recht, in dem Moment, in dem du zu viel spendest, ist es ja fast schon so, als würdest du eine Gruppe bewusst benachteiligt.
Ja, es ist wie eine Beleidigung.
Ja, angenommen, es gibt 100 Tiere und du spendest für 80.
Dann könnte man sagen, das ist ja genau so, wie wenn du den 20, für die du nicht spendest, Geld wegnimmst. Was haben die dir getan? Du hast einem geschlossenen System Ungleichheit gebracht. Ab einem gewissen Punkt kippt es. Wenn du an zu vielen verschiedenen Punkten dich beteiligst oder auch Aktionismus, dann kippt es, weil du dann wieder gewisse Ziele nicht unterstützt.
Bewusst ausschliessend.
Ich habe heute gelesen, Jeff Bezos ist ja unglaublich reich. Und um das mal zu verstehen, wie reich der eigentlich ist, gab es so ein Denkbeispiel. Wenn man im Jahre 2500 vor Christus gelebt hätte schon, bis heute gelebt hätte, und jeden Tag zehntausend Euro gespart hätte, hättest du jetzt ein Fünftel von Jeff Bezos Vermögen. Also wenn Kleopatra sagt, Leute, jeden Tag 10.000. Rürup-Rente. Kleopatra sagt Rürup. Aber ich habe natürlich viel über, viele Sklaven, schöne Pyramidchen. Ich lege mir die Eurochen beiseite und mache mir ein Taggeld.
Eine Million Eurochen jeden Tag.
So, und dann schön 10.000 Eurochen jeden Tag.
Ja, genau, eine Million Euro. Oh, wow, schnell gerechnet.
10.000 Euro jeden Tag lege ich mir beiseite.
Dann lebt die, weil die halt so gut einbalsamieren können, bis heute durch und hätte jetzt ein Fünftel nur von Jeff Bezos, obwohl sie jeden Tag 10.000 gespart hat.
Ist das nicht absurd und vielleicht falsch, aber wie absurd. Ja, das ist auch so, wenn Jeff Bezos fragt, du kannst du mir vielleicht zu 50 Euro leihen oder so?
Es gibt blöde Situationen jetzt, du kannst du mir vielleicht so irgendwie 50 Euro leihen oder so?
Es gibt blöde Situationen jetzt, aber kannst du mir 50 Euro leihen? Aber das macht doch jeder mal, dass man mal Geld nicht dabei hat.
Bei mir ist es schon unangenehm, wenn man mit Freunden unterwegs ist, die jetzt noch nicht arbeiten, weil die noch studieren oder sowas.
Finde ich schon merkwürdig, weil man könnte ja genauso gut vertauschte Rollen haben und sowas. Aber finde ich es schon merkwürdig, nach Geld zu fragen, weil man das Portemonnaie vergessen hat oder sowas. Aber jetzt in diesem Beispiel, Jeff Bezos darf niemals seine, ist ja völlig egal, weil er mit seinen Assistenten ist wahrscheinlich auch ultrareich und wird nicht mehr so viel Geld ausgeben können, wie er jemals verdient hat, oder Assistente. Wie weird ist das denn? Das ist ja bei denen vielleicht egal, wer wem was gibt. Ja. Aber der spart noch, oder? Also der spart, der sagt so, ja, ich hätte schon gerne den ganzen Monat. Ich hätte schon gerne, es wäre so viel Geld wie sechs Kleopatras, die jeden Tag Geld gespart hätten. Aber wenn fünf Kleopaträ jeden Tag 10.000 Euro gespart hätten, dann wären jetzt genauso viele. Ich tue mir schwer mit solchen Vergleichen. Manche Dinge sind einfach zu gross für den menschlichen Kopf. Das ist so, wenn du sagst, so viele Atome im Universum, wie wenn die gesamte Freiheitsstatue aus Gold wäre. Was? So wie viele Centmünzen das dann wäre. Und dasum aufgestapelt würde von hier bis zum Pluto gehen, aber so viele Stapel, wie man auf einem Fussballfeld unterbringen kann und das sind dann die Atomen im Universum, ich sag alles klar got it, jetzt habe ich es, danke und wenn man das umrechnet in Euro, wäre es immer noch ein Fünftel von Jeff Bezos Vermögen.
Vor allem, wenn ganz am Ende steht, und das ist ein Fünftel,
der sagt, ja, dann nimm doch eine andere Zeitebene.
Dann war das ja alles für den Arsch.
Ja, sag, wir wären der letzte Neandertaler.
Aber gut, hätten die doch sagen können, wenn Kleopatra,
ich weiß nicht, wie er auf die eigentlich ...
Warum haben wir sie in den Mix geworfen?
2500 Jahre vor Christus, also vor 5000 Jahren.
Nee, aber da hätte man ja sagen können, zumindest,
wenn du jeden Tag 50.000 Euro gespart hättest,
hättest du ja so viel Geld wie Jeff Bezos.
Stattdessen aber, aber natürlich macht es das cooler.
Ja, klar. Wenn man sagt, 10.000,
dann ist du jetzt ... Boah, das ist viel. Und mal fünf.
Viel mal viel, 11.
Viel mal fünf, ja, ja.
Vier mal fünf?
Vielen Dank. Ja, klar. Wenn man sagt, 10.000, dann ist es jetzt. Boah, das ist viel. Und mal fünf. Viel mal fünf, ja, ja, ja. Vier mal fünf? Viel mal fünf. Ach so, viel mal fünf. Oh, das ist ja viel. Oh, das noch mal mal fünf. Ja, ist schwierig. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Aber es gibt ja auch Inflation. Also du musst ja gucken, wenn Kleopatra hat irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 80 Cent oder je nachdem, wie das damals hieß, ich weiß es nicht, dann war ja deren 80 Cent damals so viel wert wie heute Jeff Bezos. Also das ist ja eh krude gerechnet. Also damit kommst du bei mir nicht weit. Bisschen aus dem Leben gegriffen, ne? Es ist ein bisschen aus dem Leben gegriffen. Nee. Wenn du damals ein Esel, wenn die nur ein Esel, wenn die Kleopatra, wenn die ein Esel schön verzinst hätte, nur ein Esel, wie viele Esel hat die? Wenn die nur einen einzelnen Esel, wenn die Kreopatra, wenn die ein Esel schön verzinst hätte, nur ein Esel,
wie viele Esel hat die, wenn die nur einen einzelnen Esel
da schön irgendwie mit, was weiß
ich, vier Prozent Zinsen im Jahr angelegt
hätte, die ist so dumm,
die hätten heute, wären die richtig
reich. Gab sie wirklich? Ja.
Ich glaube schon,
die haben da irgendwie so eine Statue gefunden und haben gesagt.
Ist das die lameste Verschwörungstheorie der Welt, die ich gerade erfunden habe? Dass es Kleopatra gar nicht gab und das ist stattdessen boring, ne? Glaubst du, sowas würde dann auch im Publikum bekommen? Weil, also Verschwörungstheorien haben ja zumindest, wenn die eins gemeinsam haben, und oft glauben ja auch eine Verschwörungstheorie, glaube es haben viele Dinge und so. Aber wenn die eins gemeinsam haben, dann zumindest,
dann ja, dass sie irgendwie,
wenn du da drin glaubst, in einem elitären Kreis
angehörst, weil das alles verändern würde.
Aber gibt es ja so eine, wie Kleobotag gab es nie?
Wahrscheinlich schon, oder da wurde dann halt niemand auftaucht.
Ist auch so ein bisschen egal.
Ich sag, nicht Brutus hat Caesar umgebracht,
sondern Caesar hat Brutus umgebracht. Und da hast du so eine große Turnhalle mit grossen Bannern, wo halt zwei Leute sind, einer am Buffet, legt sich was auf den Teller. Schlimms. Was? Ich sag, dass Brutus Caesar umgebracht hat, nicht andersrum. Ja, deswegen sind wir doch hier, steht auf dem Plakat hinter dir. Okay. Hast du Beweise? Ja, ich hab hier dieses Fresco gefunden. Ist das eine amerikanische Supermarktkette? Nein. Das ist Tesco. Also, ich habe hier zwei Mosaike, ein Fresco und ein Chaiselon. Also, da könnt ihr, glaube ich, guten Eindruck bekommen, weil hier, wenn ihr ganz genau hinguckt, da sind so kleine Männchen eingeritzt und da steht eigentlich Brutus, weil Brutus war grösser als Caesar. Guck, komm mal da mal näher ran, ihr seid zwei Fans. Das ist ganz klein, hier seht ihr da auf dem Fresco, weil das ist ja aufgemalt. Guck mal, das ist ja nicht Caesar, oder? Das kann doch gegen Wer sein. Nee, ist es ja nicht. Der ist ja grösser als Kulton.
Sag mal, hast du vielleicht noch Schrimps?
Ja, der Kirche ist noch ein ganzer Eimer.
Okay.
Warte kurz.
Eimer?
Gibt es aber bestimmt...
Eimer Schrimps besorgt?
Für den Abend, dass er einen Eimer Schrimps besorgt?
Hättest du?
Für diesen fiktiven... Ich hätte einen Eimer Schrimm.
Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Maßeinheit.
Für Schrimm? Ja, ja.
Ich habe ja tatsächlich mein Geld, lege ich auch an den Eimern.
Und ich glaube, schon langsam
kommt der Punkt, wo ich den Eimer entfernen muss,
wo ich das einzahlen muss. Aber ich geniesse
die Zeit noch, wo ich mich an diesem Eimer festhalten kann.
Wörtlich, bis er irgendwann durch den Boden
bricht. Eimer sind toll. Und einfach meinen Nachbarn erschlägt. Dass wir dann einmal in den True Crime Podcast kommen, oder? Dass du einfach so, Agathe B. saß an ihrem Laptop und checkte auf StudiVZ, aus welchen Gruppen sie austreten sollte. Doch plötzlich, knack, ein 30 Kilo schwerer Kleingeldeimer aus dem Nachbarn über ihn, brach durch die Decke und er schlug sie, sie war auf der Stelle tot.
Zufall oder ...
...
Dieses
... ... ... Oh, ein mysteriöser Geldeimer, der Geldeimer vorfall, der Geldeimer vorfall, wo er in den Willen will. Der Geldeimer vorfall, ich sehe nur so, ne, der kommt raus. Ja, wer hat jemals so hochgesprochen? Extra hoch sprechen, damit man abwechselnd in den Vorsprachen geschnitten wird. Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber kann sein, kann alles sein. Die Welt ist, wir leben in einer verrückten Welt, in der alles passieren kann. und möchte empfehlen, In the Dark möchte ich empfehlen, den True Crime Podcast, In the Dark, investigativer True Crime Podcast. Ist schon ein bisschen älter, gibt es aber in der zweiten Staffel. Jetzt weiß ich gerade nicht, ob das stimmt, aber gab da eine zweite Staffel. Ich bin erst bei der ersten, die ist fantastisch toll. Ich möchte empfehlen, kümmert euch um eure Probleme schnell und direkt. Bitte nicht lange liegen lassen, macht nicht denselben Fehler wie ich. Ist wieder was passiert? Ist einiges passiert. Ich habe meine komplette Küche unter Wasser gesetzt, weil mein Abfluss verstopft war. Das war eine Katastrophe. Aber ich möchte, also das ist ja so, okay, okay, okay. Also mein Abfluss war verstopft und ich dachte, so, ja, gehe ich schon hin. Und Und dann kommt ja der Punkt, erst mal, Problem wird ignoriert natürlich. Und jetzt gibt es den Pömpel-Moment. Und ich glaube, diesen Pömpel-Moment gibt es bei vielen Problemen. Weil was macht ein Pömpel? Ein Pömpel nimmt das Problem und drückt es noch tiefer rein. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Doch, der drückt es noch tiefer ein. Nein, der Pömpel ist dafür da, dass er erst mal die Situation auflockert. Ja, aber indem er es tiefer reindrückt. Der ist ja wie wir auf einer Marsmission. Erst mal ist es festgefahren, die Fronten sind verhärtet, und dann sind wir als Pömpel und lockern die Situation erst mal auf. Wir rütteln erst mal rum und dann fließt alles wieder. Und dann wird ja auch der Dreck weggeflossen. Stell dir mal so einen Ziegelstein vor im Abfluss, der plötzlich sich verkeilt, weil er so dann plötzlich quer sich verkeilt im Rohr. Das Rohr ist so und dann verkeilt es sich. Und der Pömpel ist dafür da, dass er es wieder ablockert. Mit einer rechten Hand, flachen linken Hand fährt er durch die Luft, simuliert eine Röhre, simuliert einen Kreisel, deutet jetzt auf mich, nimmt seinen Finger, er bewegt die Hüften, er bewegt die Schultern, oh da ist aber richtig Rhythmus im Blut, da ist Leidenschaft mit dabei, steht auf, bewegt sich, er dreht sich um die eigene Achse, er stellt seinen Knie auf den Stuhl und er ein Sprung und ein Rückwärtsseiltor. Oh, da ist er schlecht gelandet, jetzt setzt er sich hin, stützt sich den Rücken, setzt sich hin, greift in seinen Rucksack, zieht eine lange, rote, was ist das? Ist das etwa ein riesiger Shrimp, den grössten Shrimp, den ich je gesehen habe? Und er steckt ihn, er beißt nicht ab, er steckt ihn sich direkt so in den Mund. Er versucht ihn zu schlucken, er kann ihn nicht schlucken, er ist zu groß. Er kann ihn nicht gar nicht so unterschlucken, das geht nicht. Er kann ihn nicht unterschlucken, er steckt fest, er steckt, der Shrimp steckt in seinem Hand fest. Und was holt er aus seinem Rucksack? Einen Pömpel. Einen noch größeren Pömpel. Er setzt den Pömpel auf seinen Mundaufgesicht und pelt so groß auf mein ganzes Gesicht. Es muss ein massangefertigter Pömpel sein, der genau die Konturen von seinem Gesicht hat. Und wild nimmt er den Holzstock, pömpelt sich seine Augen, Augäpfel werden aus dem Schädel rausgesaugt und dann wieder tief reingedrückt. Ja, einmal mal durchschütteln. Und er drückt sich den Shrimp den Hals runter, nimmt den Pömpel ab und schaut zufrieden und reibt sich den Bauch. Das war lecker, sagt er. Ja, was ich jedenfalls sagen wollte, ist, dass es ja erstmal auflockert. Aber ist es nicht so dieser Q-Tip-Moment, wo du auch sagst, ich versuche das Problem zu lösen, aber dafür muss ich es erstmal reinschieben? Der Q-Tip ist ja, anders als ein Pömpel schiebt er ja etwas in eine Einbahnstrasse rein. Beim Pömpel lockert er ja das auf und fließt alles raus in die Kanalisation. Der Q-Tip schiebt es ja in Richtung Trommelfell. Warum macht der Pümpel was anderes als ein Q-Tip? Wo ist der Unterschied? Das Rohrsystem ist der Unterschied. Das Ohr ist doch auch ein Rohr, deswegen heißt er Ohr. Ja, aber das Ohr-Rohr ist ja eine Einbahnstraße, es endet ja am Trommelfell. Das geht ja nicht unendlich rein. Ja, aber du hörst doch was! Ja! Das ist ja nicht eine Sackgasse in dein Ohr. Doch, natürlich, stellst du dir vor wie ein Trommelfell. Was die, wie schwebt. Ich soll mir das Trommelfell vorstellen wie ein Trommelfell. Naja, stellst du dir halt so, ja wie ein Trommelfell. Nein, du stellst es dir gerade wie ein Hautlappen vor, stellst dir immer wie ein Trommelfell vor. Ja, aber das geht doch da durch,
durch das Trommelfell. Die Schallwellen.
Ja, die Schallwellen, weil die aufgenommen
werden von diesem Fell.
Ja, er wackelt ruckartig mit seinem Kopf.
Geht's ihm gut?
Aber nicht, ja,
klar, aber die
Orange-Mals geht ja nicht da durch.
Das ist ja kein Loch, das ist ja ein Trommelfell.
Aber wo kommt der Orange-Mals her? Kommt der nicht da durch?
Von außen. Von außen?
Klar, ist wie Popel, oder nicht?
Wie die sich bilden.
Ich stecke mir Ohrenschmalz ins Ohr rein, oder was?
Wer steckt mir das rein?
Ist Ohrenschmalz an outside party?
You know?
Ach so, die Party, die dann nachts zu dir nach Hause kommen.
Ist es nicht eine outside party?
Eine Fremde, von außen die einen wirken aufs Ohr. Ich glaube schon. Ja, aber jetzt, wo du es mir erklärt hast, ergibt Sinn. Deswegen was anderes. Das stimmt schon. Zurück zum Weinproblem. Nee, stimmt schon. Du hast den Pömpel genommen. Pömpel genommen. Hast du den vorher besessen? Ich habe ihn bestellt. Bei Pömpel bekommen? Pömpel24.de und ich habe das Gefühl, manche Produkte kann man nicht alleine bestellen, sondern da kommen... Heissen die wirklich Pömpel oder heißen die dann... Die heißen wirklich Abpömpel. Abflussrohr. Nee, die heißen wirklich Pömpel. Auflockerer. So genau so heißt es. Und es kam aber gleich Pömpel in zwei Grössen. Es kam ja so Mini-Pömpel für zwischendurch und halt der Heavy-Duty-Pömpel. Und dann habe ich das Problem erst mal noch tiefer in den Abfluss reingepümpelt,
und dann ging gar nichts mehr.
Dann lasse ich es noch mal so eine Woche ruhen, das Problem,
und jetzt habe ich mein komplettes Abflusssystem aufgeschraubt.
Das war eine Riesensauerei.
Ich habe mich zweimal fast übergeben, es war wirklich grauenvoll.
Was du gebraucht hättest, wäre ein Rohr reingepümpelt.
Habe ich auch reingekippt.
Später habe ich verstanden, warum das nichts bringt,
weil die Röhre ja hoch und runter geht.
Das heißt, wenn du den Rohrreiniger reinkippst, dann bleibt es ja im Tal. Das Tal ist nicht das Problem. Ich weiß nicht, wer noch was das Problem ist, aber... Siphon. Meinst du mit Tal das Siphon? Siphon hast du ja normalerweise bei einem Kriffenbauspeck nicht. Jetzt kommt der hier mit Siphon. Hast du mit dem Pömpel des Siphon? Also mein Fresko ist leider komplett, ich muss leider den Abschluss spülen. Und dann hängt mein Fresko im Siphon. Und dann kann ja eigentlich nur noch ein Pömpel helfen. Der Pömpel pömpelt des Freskos durch Siphon. Und so geht es dann. Das stand auf Baumarkt.de und so ging es dann eigentlich auch. Und das ging dann. Das ging dann? Ich habe alles aufgeschraubt, Riesensauerei, ich habe mich wirklich mehr als Fass übergeben. Und ich bin halt auch der größte Depp der Welt, der immer, wenn er sein Waschbecken abschraubt,
also der Abflussrohr ist
abgeschraubt und dann ist da irgendwie
dieser ganze Schlons drin, dann kippe ich
den Schlons natürlich ins Waschbecken.
Und mach an, mach die Spüle an.
Alles fließt durch und ich bin
wirklich so dumm, dass ich das dreimal gemacht habe.
Also ich lerne es heute, weil du bist so gewohnt.
Wie sauer war es auf dich? Ich war extrem sauer auf mich und ich dachte mir, wie kann man so dumm sein? Geht es noch dümmer Also ich lerne es heute, weil du bist so gewohnt. Wie sauer warst du auf dich? Ich war extrem
sauer auf mich und ich dachte mir, wie kann man so dumm sein?
Geht es noch dümmer? Irgendwann war es ein Wettbewerb.
Irgendwann war es wirklich so ein Wettbewerb wie, wie dumm kann ein
Mensch sein? Und die Antwort war noch ein bisschen
dümmer. Und dann einfach immer noch mal rein,
das war eine Katastrophe.
Vielleicht bist du nicht dumm, vielleicht warst du Dinge einfach zu wenig bewusst
oder unbewusst. Ich höre aber auch gerne Podcasts.
Hast du währenddessen einen Podcast?
Ich hatte währenddessen einen schönen Podcast auf dem Ohr.
Und deswegen hat es eigentlich Spaß gemacht, weil du musst halt gucken, wie läuft es und so und alles stinkt.
Aber sobald du was Schönes hörst, kann es dagegen wirken, wenn du was Schlimmes riechst.
Ist es nicht furchtbar, dass es gestunken hat und so eklig war?
Weil gemeint ist die Küche doch ein Ort der Reinheit, des Genusses.
Nee.
Ja, nee, ist es nicht.
Bäder und Küchen sind die ekligsten Orte. Ja. Können es zumindest schnell sein, weil die werden unfassbar dreckig und hinter den Kulissen ist da nichts mehr schön. Da ist es verschimmelt, da ist es widerlich eklig. Ja. Vor allem diese Rohre, das ist furchtbar. Nee, dieses Rohrsystem, das ist auch ein Mysterium. Also das hat ja wirklich magischen Charakter. Du steckst was in ein Loch und es ist weg. Aber das ist ja nicht weg, das ist ja irgendwo. Nee, das Problem ist vertagt worden. Das Problem ist vertagt. Und wo ist es denn dann? Und wann laufen die Rohre alle zusammen und wo geht das alles hin? Also wo endet denn wirklich jetzt, wenn ich in der Spaghetti... Ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig. Und wir schlafen, wir schlafen langsam ein. Die Rohre interessieren dich nicht mehr. Ach, aber wo ist das? Nein, du brauchst dich nicht wundern, wir haben alles hinter Kontrolle.
Brauchen Sie Hilfe?
Nee, also ich verschlüpft.
Sorry, ja.
Naja, aber es ist ja auch nicht so wild mit den Rohren, das wird schon... Ha ha ha! Brauchen Sie Hilfe? Nee, also ich verschluckt.
Sorry, ja. Naja, aber es ist ja auch nicht so wild mit den Rohren. Das wird schon irgendwie funktionieren, das wird schon irgendwie passen. Ich habe derweil Lieferservices durchgespielt. Ja? Weil mir ist aufgefallen, Moment mal kurz, wenn das Prinzip Mindestbestellwert erstmal entweder ignoriert oder nicht vorhanden ist, Dann kann man ja, wenn mir jetzt da bei diesem einen Restaurant Gericht eins gefällt, bei einem anderen Restaurant gefällt mir aber ein Nachtisch vielleicht ganz gut. Die Geisel des Proletariats. Dann habe ich jetzt neuerdings schon mal bei zwei Restaurants bestellt. Und ich hoffe immer so sehr, dass sich die Lieferboden nicht treffen. Oder dass sie sich verlieben. Verliefern. Wir haben uns verliefert. Wir haben uns verliefert. Alle zehn Minuten verliefert sich ein Lieferando-Fahrer auf bei Stefan. Aber kommt dann nicht irgendwie das Filet Mignon zuerst und dann die schönen Pommes-Döner zu spät? Muss man dann anfangen? Es kam schon mal erst das Ben & Jerry's Eis und dann das Hauptgericht, was nicht so problematisch ist. Kannst du anschmelzen lassen. Ich habe es angeschmolzen lassen. Ich habe es im Kühlschrank anschmelzen lassen. Ja, fand ich aber merkwürdig, ehrlich gesagt, von mir. Ich habe eine Lösung, aber ich habe die langsamere Lösung gewählt.
Eher die schnellere Lösung wählen können,
es im Raum stehen lassen, indem du nichts tust,
indem ich nichts mache. Aber du hast dich aktiv dazu entschieden, das Problem
noch zu verlängern. Ich habe das Problem mir
bewusst gemacht, habe aber die
langsamere Lösung bevorzugen.
Dachte aber gar nicht so unklar, weil
ich esse ja jetzt erstmal gleich, was
für Lermillon was ankommt. Dein Haus stand in Flammen
und du hast noch mit Streichhölzern noch reingeworfen, um das Feuer zu vergrößern. Aber kleine Streichhölzer. Es war letzten Endes nicht so weh. Sprengenommen eine schlechte Metapher, die du gerade anwendest, weil damit beschleunige ich oder verlangsame ich das nicht. Aber du verstärkst dein Problem. Es ist wie es brennt, das Haus brennt und ich nehme viel zu kleinen Eimer. Also ich bin dabei, es zu löschen, das Haus,
nehme aber einen sehr kleinen Eimer.
Und ersetze dann den großen Eimer durch den kleinen Eimer.
Ja, genau. Zum Beispiel.
Aber ich drehe den Schlauch halb doll auf, den Feuerwehrschlauch.
Ja, okay.
Nur so ein Fossgang.
Sorry, okay, tut mir leid, ich werde nie wieder eine schlechte Metapher in deiner Nähe benutzen.
Ja, die Metapher-Polizei kann jetzt auch abfahren.
Aber ich finde es schäbig.
Ja, ich auch. Bin ja ganz offen. Aber es passiert ja sonst nichts. Obwohl das ist natürlich, also sorry, aber einmal klar, natürlich, Arbeiter vereinigt euch, auf der anderen Seite ist es eine geile App-Idee. Eine App-Idee, eine App, in der du dir dein Gericht selber zusammenstellen kannst, das Stück Fleisch von dem Restaurant, die Soße von dem Restaurant, die Beilage von dem, Ben & Jerry's von dem, Order, und dann macht die App das selber selbstständig. Die nimmt dann die Orders. Wie die App macht das selbstständig? Nee, die App platziert dann die Bestellungen bei den verschiedenen Restaurants über die verschiedenen Sachen. Das ist die faulste App. Die App ist doch nicht faul. Du bist der faulste Mensch, wenn die App benutzt.. Warum anstatt ... Lazy Person, heißt die App Lazy Person. Ja, I'm fat and lazy. Oder halt das Podcast-UFO als die App. Aber jeder Mensch würde lieber eine Bestellung abgeben als vier, ist doch klar. Die App, das Podcast-UFO, unser Podcast, unser die App-UFO-Logo. Ja drauf, und wie hieß die App nochmal, wo man das Gericht zusammenstellen kann? Ich habe schon sechs Apps auf meinem Handy, die das Podcast-Ufo heissen. Und alle sind sehr speziell. Die haben alle dasselbe Logo und die haben alle denselben Namen. Du verstehst einfach nichts, das ist einfach merkwürdig. Aber eigentlich eine gute Idee, ne? Ja. Ja, ich bin auch hin und hergerissen. Aber manchmal, kennst du das, man kommt immer auf die Idee hin und man denkt, das kann ich nicht bringen. Aber wie boring wäre es, es nicht zu machen. Da habe ich es gemacht. Da habe ich auch erst einmal gemacht, jetzt ein bisschen uncool. Dann habe ich so gehofft, dass sie sich nicht treffen. Aber es ist mir auch danach erst eingefallen, dass sie jetzt wahrscheinlich zu gleichen Zeitgleich ankommen. Und beide klingeln dann bei mir und dann beide so, hä, weil das ist ja auch eine coole Aufgabe, du bringst jemandem was zu essen. Du bringst, du du sorgst dafür, dass der, dem du was bringst, einen coolen Abend hat. Stell dir mal vor, wie man das abwertet, wenn plötzlich noch ein anderer ist. Es ist wie Fremdgehen. Reicht dir nicht. Reicht dir nicht, was ich dir gebracht habe.
Ich hätte nicht kommen müssen.
Ja, aber mit unserer App
hättest du dann nicht mehr fünf Lieferanten,
sondern einen, der nacheinander
durch die Restaurants geht
und sich die Sachen zusammenstellt.
Und in seinem Auto hat er so eine kleine Küche
und der kocht dann die Sachen
zusammen. Also wenn du sagst, die Soße von dem einen, das Fleisch von dem anderen, dann tut er das zusammen in seiner kleinen Küche. Und dann kommt er bei dir an und hat dann nur noch eine Tüte. Okay, und dann, okay, und wenn die Kunden, du musst das auch alles warm halten, ich habe dann hier diese Brunzenbrenner. Ja, in der Küche, in der Transportküche hast du auch so einen Wärmetresor, der Code ist 8898, dann kannst du ihn aufmachen und da kannst du das Essen reintun. Code ist 8898. Warum ist das hier, warum ist das hier ein grosser Pömpel? Naja, das ist manchmal, es gibt in Köln einen Tunnel, wenn du da stecken bleibst mit deinem Wagen. Und wir beide sagen nur so, glaub mir, es ist besser, dass du ihn hast. Und er so, ja okay. Eines Tages wirst du uns dafür da. Eines Tages wirst du es verstehen, ja. Aber gute Idee, setzt es um, Leute. Die Idee ist dann raus, programmiert die App, macht das, werdet reich. Nicht immer sagen, ich wäre auch so fünfmal gern, fünfmal so reich wie Kleopatra und wo ist mein Esel und so. Und dann sagt, ich habe so wenig Geld. Nein, macht doch mal eine heiße App, programmiert das und werdet reich.
Werdet die nächste Kleopatra nach 5000 Jahren.
Wir haben gefragt, wer ist der reichste Podcast-Lofohörer?
Ja.
Und es kam nicht so viel zurück.
Nichts, obwohl es kam eine Nachricht, das waren aber so ganz merkwürdige Bildchen
mit so Menschen, die so einen Pfau hochhalten und so einen Vogel.
Das haben wir nicht verstanden.
Aber ansonsten kam gar nichts. Vielleicht, weil die andere Sachen benutzen, weil die reichen Menschen auf den reichen Samsung-Telefonen, den goldenen, die nur untereinander erreichbar sind oder sowas. Nee, ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen, die muss ich mal suchen. Wir können das nächste Woche mal alles sammeln von jemandem, der sagt, er hat 200.000 Euro, weil er irgendwie in Bitcoins oder so angelegt hat und so. Das ist nicht so wenig Geld. 200.000 ist eine Menge Schotter. Ja, eine Menge Eurlinge. Menge Esel. 200.000 Euro sind nämlich wie viele Eurochen? 20 Millionen. 20 Millionen Eurochen. Wow. Wow. Wir schauen mal, wie dieser Kampf ausgehen wird, wie unsere Währung demnächst heisst. Hat Bitcoin eigentlich eine Unterordnung? Gibt es Bitcent? Das ist eine Möglichkeit. Bitcent. Bitlinge. Bitchen. Gerade heisst es ja auch 0,000 0,0006 Bitcoins. Nein, wir brauchen bessere Worte. Wir brauchen Quarters, wir brauchen Bitling. Bytes vielleicht. Bitcoins. Ein Achtel dann, oder was? Sag mal nicht, Bits und Bytes?
Das wäre ein Achtel Bitcoin, das hilft dir aber nicht so viel, oder?
Das ist mega kompensiert.
Bytecoin. Ihr kriegt das schon raus.
Ihr kriegt das hin.
Ihr müsst nicht immer alle eure Probleme, ihr kriegt das schon raus.
Kilo-Bitcoin, Mega-Bitcoin,
Terabytecoin.
Es wird eine aufregende Woche,
wir sammeln alle eure Ideen und teilen sie euch nächste Woche mit.
Wir wünschen euch bis dahin ganz, ganz viel Spaß.
Ich wünsche euch eine ganz tolle Woche, wisst ihr das?
Ja.
Nee, echt geniess die Woche, habt eine schöne Woche.
Habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, wir heben so lange ab.
Macht's gut, ciao.
Ciao, ciao, bis wir sind immer nicht so weit weg.
Ciao, ciao, ciao.